97 year-old Cubs fan who attended the
Cubs last World Series in 1945 he's 97
and just loves the Cubs that's his whole
life will now thanks to a Good Samaritan
this was in the news he's just been
given a front-row seat to see the Cubs
play in this year's World Series I think
that's a great thinking about it I was
thinking about it and it gave me a great
idea
we found a fan who attended my very
first show taping on September 13th 1993
23 years ago we flew him in we gave him
a front row seat to tonight's show his
name is Robert woz Neal it's give him a
hand
thank you thank you for being here
Robert I really appreciate it really
good to have you here thank you
this was our common always a big thing
all right well thank you we are so happy
that you're here tonight sitting in the
front row let's have a big hand for our
number one fan
[Applause]
wait wait a minute wait a minute it's he
okay will someone see if he's all right
someone see if he's okay have you got a
paramedic here which is oh my god oh my
god that's Ted no not the balloons stop
the balloon the balloon No
congratulations here's your gift basket
no no no barrel don't give him a gift
basket he's dead he passed away how
how's he gonna use his new car what new
car what do you mean
[Applause]
now stop close the curtains this is
terrible
[Applause]
this is awful where's the paramedic
no more balloons
[Applause]
what's wrong with you people someone
died and you're just happy to see
balloons your animals look at this
they're the paramedic died using a
pillow or as a pillow I know I might as
well become full of company up I'm gonna
die right well fittingly we got an
amazing show tonight from the AMC series
biggest show on television The Walking
Dead Steven Yeun is on
[Applause]
from Coldplay from Coldplay Grammy
award-winning singer-songwriter
guys then they take a break we'll be
right back Jimmy go
you